if the history of the earth was a
basketball game at what point in the
game will the humans show up
let's first think about how long a
basketball game is in the nba we have
four quarters that each last 12 minutes
so we're talking about 48 minutes
48
minutes of regulation play i'm not
considering half time and the timeouts
and the commercial breaks and potential
overtime i'm just talking about
regulation play we can think about how
the numbers might change if you think
about the total duration of a game
including timeouts and commercial breaks
and everything that might get you closer
to two or two and a half hours but 48
minutes we can actually convert to
seconds because we know that there are
60 seconds per minute times 60 seconds
60 seconds per minute
and this is pretty straightforward
multiplication we can just say 48
48 times 60
gives us well we got this 0 here and
then 6 times 48 6 times 8 is 48 and then
6 times 4 is 24 plus 4 is 28 so there's
2 80 seconds 2
seconds
during regulation play
now let's think about the actual age the
actual age of earth we estimate that the
earth and actually the entire solar
system which was all formed roughly at
the same time
is 4.54 billion years old so let me draw
that here we're going to make a
comparison so i'm going to draw it as
the same length so
4.54
billion
billion years old and just to give a
sense of how large of a number that is a
billion is a thousand million so we
could also write this as 4540
million
million years or we could write it as
four million five hundred and forty
thousand
thousand years or millennia
thousand or we could just write out the
number as four billion five hundred and
forty
million
540 million years
which seems kind of old but now let's
think about how long anatomically modern
humans have been roaming the surface of
the earth and here we estimate that
anatomically modern humans have been on
the surface of the earth for about 200
000 years
200 000 years which seems like a
reasonable amount of time but we'll see
it's a very small fraction when you
compare it to 4.54
billion years so let's say that that's
that little there and i'm actually
overdoing it when i'm drawing the
diagram so that right over there is the
amount of time humans have been 200 000
years and i'm actually drawing this way
too big but we want to figure out is
what is that equivalent length what is
that equivalent length in seconds on a
basketball game or another way to think
about it two hundred thousand
two hundred thousand years
years is to
4.54 billion years
4.54
billion
billion years
years as
as the number of seconds so let's just
call this let's just call this thing
right over here x
as x is as x is to the total number of
seconds in a game so 2 80 seconds
2
80 seconds
seconds just like that and one way that
we can do this to solve for x and this
is kind of a more basic algebra but just
as a reminder if we want to solve for x
here the easiest way is to multiply by
2880
and not and that will cancel with this
right over here but we can't just do it
to the right hand side we also have to
do it to the left hand side and so if
you multiply both sides by two thousand
eight hundred and eighty
so multiply both sides by two thousand
eight hundred and eighty you get you get
that x the number of the equivalent
number of seconds in a basketball game
if the history of the earth was a
basketball game when the humans would
show up is equal to the fraction of
earth's history that humans have been
around that's this part right over here
times the number of seconds in a game so
let's think about what that what we get
there
so we're going to have the fraction of
earth's history so 200 000 200 000
divided by 4.54 billion there's a couple
of ways i could write it i could write
it
4.54
e 9 which literally means 4.54 times 10
to the ninth or 4.54 times 1 followed by
with nine zeros or 4.54
times a billion which is exactly 4.54
billion so i could write it like that or
or i could just write it out i could
write four five so four billion let me
be careful
4 billion
540
million and now i'm doing the thousands
2 3 and now i'm just doing the 1 2 3. so
this is 4 billion and then i should have
9 places after that 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9.
so this expression right here is a
fraction of earth's history that
anatomically modern humans have been
around and then i'm going to multiply
that i am going to multiply that
times
i'm going to multiply that times the
number of seconds of regulation play 2
80.
and now drumroll
we get
0.12 we could round to 0.13
seconds
so we get x
is equal to or i could say maybe
approximately equal to
approximately 0.1
0.13 seconds and so just to imagine if
the history of earth where the regular
regulation play of an nba game and let's
say this game is kind of is is at the
end of this game there's a buzzer beater
shot that wins the game
the humans don't show up in the game
until the ball has left that final shot
taker's hands and it has just about to
enter the basket that's when the first
humans 200 000 years ago will show up so
a little over a tenth of a second before
the end of the game
and since we already have our brains in
this mindset i'll throw out another
interesting question okay humans have
you know there's just a flash that
they've actually shown up just you know
the ball is about to go into the basket
we have a little over a tenth of a
second left in the game think about when
the dinosaurs went extinct
and i'll give you a hint here the
dinosaurs went extinct so we believe an
asteroid hit the earth or this is kind
of the meteorite this is the current
theory meteorite hit the earth
mass extinction event
65.5 million years ago
so if we think of that 65.5 million
years ago relative to the history of the
earth and if the history of the earth
were just regulation play of a
basketball game when did that happen
well once again let's get our calculator
out
so what fraction of the earth's history
ago was this
65.5 million i could write this as
60.5.5
times 10 to the sixth
which is that and then i'll just divide
that by 4.54
billion years
so times 10 to the ninth and so this is
the fraction of earth's history that has
happened since the extinction of a
dinosaur extinction of the dinosaur so a
little more than about a percent and a
half of earth's history has happened
since the extinction of the dinosaurs
65 and a half million years ago and if
we're talking about a basketball game
let's just multiply that times the
number of seconds in a basketball game
2880
and we get about 41 seconds so less than
with less than a minute left in the
fourth quarter is when the is when the
meteorite hits the earth and the
dinosaurs go extinct